versus Jesus in the earth yeah well it's
not a man alive that can beat me but
Jesus ain't alive is he so I don't know
maybe you could come back from the dead
nah I don't know and I'd still whoop I
travel around the world that people know
that I'm Irish and I love Ireland's well
when I graduated from the University I
didn't even go back to America I went
back to my roots and way back to Ireland
I love Ireland
I love martial arts I try to train them
as much as I can and people see oh so
you're a Connor of fans they know I hate
Connor and I don't hate people because
my general pair that don't hate people I
used to dislike Connor but now I hate
him
and when I tell people why they're
shocked because they assume right away
maybe okay me because could be because
kabhi was a Muslim and you're almost
slimming he's gonna be fighting no doubt
the Brotherhood that I had with khabib
it brings me together with him because
he's my brother in Islam no doubt about
that but this is not the reason why I
hate Connor so the reason why I hate
Connor is because of my love for Jesus
and the people are shocked you're a
Muslim see of them my son is named Lisa
my son is named Jesus ISA by the way in
Irish they say ISA as well so any my
love for Lisa for Jesus is the reason I
hate Conor McGregor obviously when it
comes to his his arrogance and his
attitude and his horrible manners I mean
I'll check out some booze a party I
never near my backwards many people
dislike him even the Irish people
himself because the Irish people have
some of the best manners on the face of
the earth when you come to Ireland the
best people to deal with beautiful
people people who'll be with Irish
people at my local dojo anywhere
everybody who there trains there is not
Muslim except for me and my son
the children asked our coach to take
down the poster he had on the wall of
Conor McGregor because of these bad
manners and his horrible attitude that
he has an arrogance that he has why do I
hate Conor McGregor because of what he
said about Jesus it's not a monologue
that can be made but Jesus ain't alive
is he so I don't know maybe you could
come back from the dead nah I don't know
I'd still when it came to the Nate Diaz
fight for the ideas fight he was asked
some time before that about it's one of
these TMZ paparazzi Joker's came to and
asked him if Jesus were to come back
because obviously he was he was beating
everybody and even you look at him have
respect no doubt he's a great fighter
and I used to be I used to be a fan of
his because of his work ethic because of
his fighting style it was very good then
I started to dislike him obviously but
went with the attitude and then in the
in the arrogance and who he became and
some on even some people who knew him
and Dublin and train with him in the
past they told me that even his father
dislikes who the man he has become the
point is that when he said this with
this TMZ a reporter asked him if Jesus
were to come back and you were to fight
Jesus who would win it's not a man alive
that can be me but Jesus ain't alive is
he so I don't know maybe you could come
back from the dead nah I don't know
I'd still whoopers a haha and he said
that he was a bit hesitant and that's
where he should he should have stayed in
his Lane he shouldn't have talked about
Jesus he said that even if Jesus were to
come back he said I would whoop his ass
I wouldn't be left he was asked about it
in the press conference before the da's
fight and he said that no no me and
Jesus now weren't cool he made even
worse now he said me and Jesus are cool
and me and Jesus are killed I'm killed
with all the gods gods recognize gods he
said gods respect other gods or gods
recognize other gods so here when he
said this right away I told the brothers
I said look this is a sign that he's
gonna lose soon and he's gonna lose bad
he's gonna be humiliated I said don't
forget the story of that side 10 when
they said not even God can sync it and
when it left from Ireland as well when
it left what happened
God humiliated them and God sent a sign
to all of mankind about the power of God
when he sucked that ship that couldn't
be sunk by anyone even God so pennilyn i
said he's going to lose and he's going
to lose bad I didn't know who's gonna be
in the D s fight or not because Nate was
he already was only nine days notice but
sure enough look how God who milli ated
this arrogant individual who called
himself a God in the second round and
just just look at it look at his face
how he was choked out and just
humiliated in that fight and this is why
I hate Conor McGregor because of not and
I decide disliked him of who he became
from the arrogance but I hated him
because of what he said about Jesus and
as Muslims we love Jesus and we don't
allow and we don't accept anyone saying
anything negative